next we're gonna take a look at a very
sharp game that you played in 2015
against Lee Chow at the cutter masters
open and I believe this this tournament
open tournament I mean you're not
playing so many big opens no easily but
this was an exception this one yeah I
was it was a very strong open tournament
I started pretty poorly for me with a
drop in the first game and then in the
second second game that was was a lot
worse at some point but after that it
all turned out pretty well and by this
point and the fifth round I had four and
a half Serena and three and a half and
out of foreign and I know when I was in
business so
and ended up winning the German yeah I
don't know predetermined with and your
playoff against Syria game it's we both
had seven out of nine so did in the end
it turned out to be a pretty pretty nice
experience so he plays prepares to play
the grin fold I see almost always place
well like old Chinese he does play a bit
of like I should say a lot of Chinese
players he also plays a bit of slop but
beautiful this is main so I got f3 which
I play from from time to time take a lot
of players play that from time to time
the anti-griddle move which is very
sharp which is both the attraction and
the dangerous double-edged yeah it's
established exactly so we follow the
main line f5 is a popular move there's
also Queen d6 there's e5 but anyway I'm
sorry I don't
I mean there c5 here Green Knight before
and creates this definitely took me by
by surprise and usually it goes a 5 here
but there were some points to why you
wanted to go Queen Eve to go Queen e8
first which I cannot I cannot really
ever cycle at this point I think it but
after thinking for a while I guess I
came up with some of the same ideas as I
did in my game against Nakamura that I'm
just gonna talk away the King huh
um and we are playing a bit of a waiting
game here that in that he wants to go
Bishop e6 at some point and then I want
to go night afore and I'm gonna go h4
well in this case I totally wanted to
want to go a six but let's say he has as
he asked on King edge shake and became
to talk the bishop away ahah and I don't
really want to move that night
meanwhile let's say here amongst other
things then g5 could be it could be a
massive issue I don't know maybe 93 but
in general 93 let some instructor point
but but the point is I don't want to
play Knight f4 before yes cut Bishop e6
so becomes sort of a waiting game at
this moment yeah because that's a very
natural move for him that he's probably
looking to play but it's a good moment
for you to tuck their king away when you
can respond with the knight move you
want to yeah I play it absolutely
so now he goes a 5 here Queen f7 could
be met by Knight g5 there's no longer a
knight a 2 so a 5 is natural he prepares
some attack and whenever I go a 3 you
might just ignore it seemed like a 3/8
aibee aibee is almost always gonna be
bad for me uh-huh I go Bishop e2 c6
I'm Roxy one and now I've actually
turned the lawn castle into a short cast
yeah which is always very comfortable
you don't like the king being that close
to the center when I'm hacked this way
it's definitely more compact this way
yeah
and after he went King h8 he's coulda
gone Bishop e6 but here also there was
nice for even Knight g5 um and probably
it's still good for for white but he
goes tonight King I hate them Here I am
still waiting um still waiting on him to
make his move looking at one is very
useful there is no longer any f4 Bishop
f5 check and at this point we sort serve
both met all our useful moves and he he
kind of he has run of he's run out of
options here so he he goes Bishop e6 the
six one light I guess yeah yeah he
starts two plates to play concretely
loud Queen f7 is always met by Knight g5
so he wants to line up over here but he
doesn't video doesn't really have that
time he goes Bishop e6 neither for Ben
f7 and now strategic considerations are
thrown out the window and I create game
on at this VI game on definitely
she could take an A - I'm gonna go eight
h5e FICO's age five himself I imagine I
can just break it all open with with G
for FG + 96 make contact yeah stuff is
gonna open up here yeah look this is
gonna be pretty bad friend I think um
yeah no I'm just getting the point that
here if you had gone Mike I shouldn't go
matter for necessarily because of
because he does have Queen f7 so I
should probably go Knight g5 is that
okay yeah so if he can meet 95 with
Bishop g8 that's a little different but
yeah yeah for sure but was denied it for
you usually wants to be put the clean up
side that's that's a that's a very
relevant point there so there was a
serious shift in these last few moves
where it was this waiting game you're
trying to both play as many useful
consolidating loose you can and then all
of a sudden it gets sharpened you know
that you're gonna be trying to kill each
other yeah and exactly because he has
put the King on a shade here then I know
that once the H file opens then his king
is gonna be in a lot of trouble and it's
gonna be even worse than having the King
on on th because I'm gonna get something
with would check or I know so pawn
running all the way to HT track position
yeah
and it seems to me we can see the
comparison of the two structures to even
though there's a cemetery here with King
a1 King h8 he's made more pawn moves on
the Kings side so you can hit his pawns
a little easier just as we were talking
about there and down again yeah that's
what that's for sure
okay let's just see what happens so here
you could have gone he I go h4 I don't
care about day two anymore I think a
five gone a three you might have have
some options like 94 is somewhat slowing
me someone's lying the down
h4 maybe a sperg fda's doesn't look bad
for like yeah but it yeah it's it's
interesting like even after she's taking
them taking on a - now my king is sort
of safe still like it's gonna take a lot
to make him I feel like even if he gets
a four a three then I'm gonna happy
three so it's not gonna be made quite
yet so I feel like I'm some some leeway
there and now that I'm now that I'm
attacking right okay so anyway h5 King
Jade's not much else to do if g5 I have
many good options I can go h6 just
forcing the opening over files in
special p5 fails because b6 is tiny nice
and I could simply win the exchange
about lines yeah that's pretty good
nice chapter yeah all because of this
connect eight move which was desirable
from a strategical point of view but it
turned out that concretely concretely
didn't read it didn't with the panelled
room so we got King J it's obviously I
opened the lines now that I have the
chance takes and I go g4 and as
mentioned earlier on a 4 GF a3 I just
could be three yeah and and he is not in
time simply yeah bishops trapped yeah he
doesn't you know he's gotta go Bishop b3
um but here I imagine that this should
win just off the top of my head's real
d3 here I could imagine even rook AJ
it's very strong
mr. Bates a queen 8h two shades of our
friend
Damiano again maybe maybe I'm getting
ahead of myself maybe Rick f7 is
throwing a bit of a spanner it works
there
I guess throwing an e-cig somewhere also
comes to mind a lot of things comes to
come to mind I think also night g6 I
don't see why that is not just very
strong Queen at five it's never possible
yeah I just kind of wanted to make
immediately but I think 96 should be
very very good also I'm seeing I'm
seeing now other ideas like there's even
let's say takes rook h5 also maybe in
tank them there's even this although I
probably wouldn't want to go for that
doesn't work but I think 96 should be
very strong yeah basically I just have
to calculate precisely which is hard to
do here on here very strong position on
the spot yeah yeah but basically yeah
just it could check it out the eight
works
so here the point of Bishop III when she
plays in the game is that in case of GF
you can go green and five and the bishop
is not hanging on run a two so that is
not as effective anymore this is
probably just best chance yeah
so now I need to clear out I need to get
Queen to h2 and that is why I go mission
to D one yeah and then the note says the
ambush basics is creative one
nice job Kristoff and Peter blocking the
ephod quite importantly as far as we
will see and four variants to pitch but
I think Bishop d1 is a lot more yeah
it's a lot more each I say if it takes
it I'm not even gonna bother I'm just
gonna go Queen inch to route 58 I got a
six
Queen i7 old brute force just winning
the game do ya 97 g5 yes straight Jagga
not for the claustrophobic no no
so g5 would be Thanks but sugars at this
point so instead he comes up with with a
for preparing a 3 which would if he were
to move I think he would he would win
with with a 3 so I have to act quite
quite swiftly yeah price of a single
move is so high at this point yeah so
Queen age 7 King f8 and then t5 yeah
this one it looks like a very simple
when I'm cutting up the coordination or
his pieces here it means that whatever
piece he takes with d5 on let's say the
Knights I'm just going to go east six
and as we talked about in the earlier
line that these these lines are always
waiting for White Queen f6 we got g5 for
instance and that's that's just gonna
win the game immediately I like how you
said it looked like a simple way because
I was thinking man this looks like a
complete mess but when you think about
it in terms of the tactical reason why
you do this which I assume is to block
the bishop from controlling e6 yeah
exactly
that's that's the that's the whole point
or really also I mean I'm preparing 96
and but but yeah that the key the key is
all about these ue6 square and Bishop g5
I guess I'm just gonna take all night
yeah I'm through cereal yeah just a
three stuff not even not even close and
just take the rook or whatever bread
but he added them yeah yeah we got to
give leech out credit cuz yeah I really
came out some fighting ideas which I
hadn't seen it when he went for nine c4
my first thought is that wow this was
pretty amazing but like it cannot work
yeah it doesn't work so the point is
simply ye 683 yeah I'm just gonna make
it like there's unreal yeah it's just
I'm nothing close to salvation here it's
just uh sure Bates
this shows you guys I mean one thing
that's been helpful for me over the
years is framing a decision in a game on
a spectrum you know in some slower
positions where the value of a move is
not very high you can afford to take
your time you can play moves that don't
greatly impact the the flow of the play
but a position like this taking your
time is gonna get you killed
so I think it's so important to just
have that in mind when you're trying to
frame the position yeah how high is the
price of a move exactly and once you
realize that you realize that II six
doesn't do anything it's threatened it's
the Queen
yeah so what yeah you know you don't
have time cuz you're gonna get Maintenon
the next move you don't have to lose and
that's why I used to take first
howdy check in with check and if it does
take that I or okay shades and that's
going on that's my salon that's gonna be
checkmate so we have to go connect ecigs
and now the big idea is that I'm gonna
get the Queen would check mm-hmm and
that makes all the difference in the
world
yep and she has no choice
she has to go away three plain Queen f6
would be like what you were showing
before a queen of six there are any
number of wins here ruk h8 I think is
made everything coming was take temples
attack you know yeah just don't even
think about my g5 this point cuz yeah
yeah
so he also yeah he doesn't have the time
so you go say three and now I've gotten
the quick check which like when you
calculate this is the first moment you
get to like this is huge
getting the getting the queen with
actually getting the Queen my check
like you've achieved something so it may
not be enough but you achieved a great
deal and
and that's why
that's why I was very optimistic that
that I was going to find something and
obviously before I went 90 g6 had
calculated everything after I'd
recovered from the shock from 94 but I
think you don't give up when you get to
this point this point you feel like
there is there is something yeah and you
always want to look at the possible
checks and then this comes into mind 95
which is a very disruptive check
I'm just threatening to take on c4
without that night
threatening me - it has no attack
anymore so 95 is obviously not an option
I can even go Bishop takes p3 and um
everything is is pretty pretty nice and
safe so he has to technically that's
this only real real choice and so a
group queen
quit at five check and now he has a
problem now he has this huge problem
that he would love to make a move which
does not allow quintic z5 check but
there is just no square for for the King
here mmm
King d6 it's gonna run into at the very
least Queenie six followed by Queen xe5
next and otherwise you just have Queen
c7 and now we're at 25 nice
and yeah I calculated this for a long
time but I couldn't find any even
glimmer of hope for him and it turns out
here that everything works out so well
for me because his key is exposed in c7
that 93 which would look
which would look like a very strong move
with some of the same things that just
runs into might be five Kinkos I just
taken a three right that's just too much
material he's running on ammunition at
this point yeah and just notice by the
way that after 95 the bishop actually
helped take him on b3 which was one of
the major points of going bishop d1 at
this point the fact that it not only
clears the line for the Queen but it
actually might end up pointing that
Bishop on b3 at some point it makes a
huge difference to me about the bishop
is B is attacking b3 that's why I like
it more than Bishop a6 had I seen the
idea with Knight see four and A three
giving up the Queen a bit earlier
I might have given more priority to to
blocking the a file but we'll forgive
you for missing that one yeah I'm never
happy to hear that
so yeah after what happened in the game
95 was the important mode to find now
it's it's all over he took company to
never there's never any Roque three
tricks just getting that rook and so he
he he thought for a long time around
here after he'd taken the roof yeah
that's that's a little surprising
because he probably I think he really
understood its losing yeah he understood
I think he just I don't know he didn't
want to to resign it have been such a
fascinating game but yeah but he had to
keep it going
a bit longer but there was really
nothing after what happened in the game
I'm so much more much material up here I
cannot even comment and actually just to
bishops against the rook and the pawn up
but I got this pastor oh never serve
them as well as as well as pretty good
coordination so he resigned because of
94m Bishop e6 right yeah and this one
turned out to be after age 4 if it's
really old tactics yeah but I think if
you do take the time to make moves such
as King b1 rook c1 Bishop Bishop e2 rook
c1 King a1 when the position does
require it you give yourself a better
chance of having the tactics work in
your favor which is all of you really
which is all your what really want if
you want to play chess at the very high
level yeah if you want to go for for an
attack from the very start then and not
care about anything else then good for
you but then you should do it tune into
another I think that's it's such an
important point you made about strategy
not necessarily being slower positional
stuff yes granted a big part of strategy
is recognizing change in the pace of
play X and how things just shifted on a
dime after these preparatory moves were
made for both sides and like we said
game on after a certain point and then
it's time to calculate it's time to get
specific yeah exactly and for for me
it's like I I sort of prefer to play
more slowly and prevent counter play but
at certain points like here h4 first of
all just looks so good
and also concretely thinking well if I
go a3 then he's got 9 c4
it doesn't doesn't look like I'm really
in time to get anything and then you
start thinking maybe this is the moment
he's gone King edge shades Bishop a3 a2
is not really a threat maybe this is the
one moment the one opportunity that I
that I have to actually play for the
attack and as the game showed I think
this was it yeah yeah highly instructive
and this sharp victory propelled you to
overall victory in the tournament
waiting that playoff against you young
yeah then I met a few draws and I wanna
beat mother earth with with life which
turned out to be to be enough so
definitely good memories from from that
game and overall the extra back okay
we're looking forward to seeing more
sharp masterpieces like this this
victory against the Li Chiao